a ceasefire between Afghan forces and
the Taliban has ended with reports of
renewed fighting on Wednesday morning
the end of the three-day ceasefire on
Tuesday night came after hundreds of
Taliban prisoners were released as part
of a us deal with the insurgent group
the ceasefire was announced by the
Taliban for the Eid celebrations at the
end of Ramadan
these men are among hundreds of
prisoners the Afghan government has
released as part of a three-day
ceasefire deal with the Taliban removed
most here were not expecting I spent six
and a half years in Bagram prison I'm
still almost speechless it's such a
surprise it's only when I saw reporters
that I realized we're free we have no
media access inside the prison I didn't
know we'd be free today before being
released prisoners had to sign written
pledges not to take up arms again as per
the guidelines of our leaders and based
on the agreement we will not return to
the battlefield we are committed to the
leadership's orders and we will continue
our life normally after nearly 19 years
of fighting many here hope this
ceasefire could mark a turning point as
does the Afghan government who've
released these prisoners in an effort to
extend peace talks with the Taliban we
request that the ceasefire continues so
that the Afghan people can rest and that
we can turn this peace effort that we
have made into a process that will pave
the way for the release of all prisoners
and the forthcoming peace talks
while the status of these talks remains
fragile and any possible outcomes still
lie far in the future this ceasefire has
given these men a new lease on life for
more now let's cross straight over to
Kabul where correspondent Ali Latifi is
covering events for us on the ground
there tell us what's the status of the
ceasefire now that this prisoner release
has happened so it seemed as if the
ceasefire is holding there were a couple
of instances in the east of the country
you implemented by both sides of the
conflict but so far it seems as if it's
holding but one thing is I was recently
in mind on one of that province in the
east and I saw that you know there were
convoys of released Taliban prisoners
coming down the road you know with
flowers and and cameras and you know
1012 cars at a time welcoming them back
and what was really interesting is that
on the road from the provincial capital
to the districts where usually there's
very little security forces presence
especially out on the road itself with
their vehicles and with the actual
police and military you saw that this
time not not only were the convoys
passing by but that there were military
Humvees and that there were police
forces stopped on the road ready in case
anything happened but so far it seems as
if you know the tall of bond is making
sure that their prisoners get it get
back safely without being caught in
crossfire and without risking anything
and I think that the government is being
overly cautious to make sure that you
know their worst fear of these people
returning to battle doesn't come true
what does this prisoner release mean for
the peace process in Afghanistan because
there's a lot riding on the negotiations
underway currently between the Taliban
and the Afghan government it's actually
a very big deal because what we're
seeing is that the Taliban has reacted
very positively their representative in
Doha their spokesman in Doha sent out
you know a statement saying that they're
happy with what the other side is doing
which is a very different use of
terminology and their reference to the
Kabul
government they also assured that they
would start releasing more of the
government prisoners in considerable
amounts they said so the hope is that
because the Taliban
you know implemented this ceasefire
themselves after a very bloody month of
April the hope is that this prisoner
release will give some confidence to the
Taliban and it will also give some
confidence to the government that these
fighters won't return to the battlefield
and that you know finally these intra
avilon talks can become much more of a
reality and and they can move towards
actually holding them Ali thank you so
much for bringing us up to date that was
correspondent Latifi there in Kabul